[music playing]
What the hell is
that supposed to mean?
No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
[laughs] And there she went.
[music playing]
Are you Steve Carell?
No.
I get that a lot.
I'm not.
OK.
Yeah.
I thought he was a lot shorter.
What the hell is
that supposed to mean?
What do mean a lot shorter?
Everybody thinks I'm 5' 8".
So you are Steve Carell?
No.
[laughter]
I love when stuff
like this happens.
What I love about
Vegas is you never know
who you're going to bump into.
so, you want to buy anything?
I would like to buy something.
I've been looking
for one of these.
The World War II,
a divers knife.
OK.
Yeah.
So it's a knife, and a
bottle opener, and a corkscrew.
And a billy club.
I know that's what
you were going for.
[laughter]
Oh.
Yeah.
Serrated.
What is the going price
on a diver's knife?
- $2,500.
- OK.
You know what?
I will give you 4,000.
How about 5?
5,500.
- $3,200, it's a deal.
- 6,000.
[laughter]
I could spend hours in
here just looking around.
I think I'm going to be
back in the shop tomorrow.
I've got some stuff
I want to sell.
Namely, this suede jacket.
I was wondering if I
might look at that Mark
Twain signature piece?
Sure.
Thanks.
Wait a minute.
Katie Holmes?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Although I'd like to
look like Katie Holmes.
Winslet?
Kate Winslet?
Really?
- Katy Perry?
- Definitely no.
No.
- I got this, Corey.
All right.
Katie Couric, how's it going?
Fine.
Thank you.
Your employees are not
particularly helpful,
I've got to be honest.
Good help is hard to get.
So tell me about this.
This is a Mark Twain signature.
He used to give these out.
He'd scratch little
things on a card, sign it.
And this one's even dated.
January 1900.
Cool.
It's a great piece of advice.
We ought never do wrong
when anyone is looking.
[laughter]
- Yeah.
That's excellent advice.
How much are you looking for--
for this?
- $20,000.
- Really?
Mhm.
Oh, it's a little more
than I wanted to spend.
How much would you give me?
What about 12?
[music playing]
- Deal.
- Really?
Sold?
- Yeah.
It's not every day we
get Katie Couric in here.
We have a deal.
- Give me five.
[laughter]
I think maybe he threw
me a bit of a bone.
A woman came in
with this platinum
record signed by Bret Michaels.
If this thing is legit, it
is definitely worth money.
And I know the exact guy
who can give me that info.
What is going on, man?
Good to see you, Rick.
Good to see you.
Doing good, brother?
- Doing good, man.
Good.
[gasps]
Hello.
How are you doing?
- Oh, my god!
Oh, my gosh!
Shut up!
[laughs] And there she went.
[laughter]
Come in.
Hi.
How aer you doing?
I don't know
why, but a girl has
never reacted like that to me.
[laughs]
- All right.
So this plaque and
platinum record
was to commemorate all the
sales combined together,
both Poison and myself.
But we did it for my
foundation, right?
And for charity.
And we only made a
limited amount of these.
This particular plaque
is awesome to me
because as a lifelong type 1
diabetic, I do a lot of stuff
with charities.
And this plaque was
made specifically
for charitable events.
And it raises a lot of money.
And we've only made
so many of these.
Very limited edition.
Sometimes it can be around
5,000, in that area.
We've sold them for 30,000.
Well, I've got to figure
out a price with her.
I totally understand, but
do not let him be hard on you,
all right?
I'm promising, do not--
- OK.
Go big on this, all right?
I'll tell you what,
I'll give you $2,500.
What about 3,500?
$2,500 is it.
I mean, can we do this?
- OK.
Sounds good.
- We got a deal?
- Deal.
OK.
Tell me you bought it.
- I bought it.
- OK.
And now you can auction it
off at your charity again.
And--
- For real?
For real.
It worked out great.
She got money.
I get a tax write off.
And you get to
auction it off again.
Awesome, dude.
So when you see me tomorrow
night, you going to let me on
stage again?
- Done.